hello breech piece of book that is uh
currently available
in 1970 author donald green was working
at a
financial firm in manhattan when
renowned
uh person bill gates came in and asked
him to invest in
the youtube.com hello donald green got
his
foot in the door next slide
while he was doing this he was also
writing books
first book he wrote is called breach of
peace there's about two
cop cops and oh i read it many people
have pointed out how the characters and
breach of peace are similar to
other characters and in many ways the
writing is also
bears resemblance to certain writing
like stephen king
stephen hawking myers-briggs joe
joe anaconda there does not appear to be
much influence in the will of time
series and that is because
daniel green has never read the wheel of
time i put put at
donald green on twitter and i said did
you actually read the books or did you
spark note it he said i read
winter heart and dragon bone chair and i
said what's the name of the one after
dragon reborn and he said
that he has two lawyers
donald green author of breach of peace
pieces he
has absolutely read all of robert
jordan's
wheel of time series there is no doubt
in my mind that
donald green is a good man who has
absolutely read the wheel of time this
uh concludes my video essay and thank
you for watching
[Music]
is that the last slide okay